stuff that's a lie i'm
not doing this anymore
that is a lie
bro we're living in a different era now
it's a lie
i'm he's a liar
what's good party people um
let's get through the mumbo jumbo you
know the vibes you know the drill you
know there's
starts of p rhymes just makes me on
um three pound a month guys three pounds
a month tempe a day
it's really not that much money and it
makes a big difference to your lives
mainly
mm-hmm and a little bit of difference to
our lives there we go it benefits you it
benefits you more than it does ask
what's three-pound going to do for me
a fuck-all what's your power to do for
you cuz so much more
juicy content so much more but um yeah
jump in um and uh yeah guys
enjoy the new merch enjoy the current
match
um enjoy this episode if you like
the video big man do me a favor and like
the video
if you like that hard it's not that hard
did i get it
um yeah man if you like the video like
the video dude
if you um love the video
comment on it if you like the audio
leave a little review
make sure you're subscribing make sure
the notifications are on make sure
you're interactive make sure you're on
the instagram make sure you're on
twitter
make sure you're on everything bro
because we are worldwide
and we can't keep up with you on all
these different platforms so you have to
keep up with us there we go we're moving
fast
we're not gonna look back for you man
you better keep up
we're moving fast brav oh so yeah
um if it's right with you i actually
have a fun fact today oh
yes i like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you'd like this one of course i will
i'll be honest so
there's actually like a meme that i saw
on instagram okay actually you know
someone sent it to me
okay on instagram okay so after a male
octopus breeds with a female he develops
dementia
he then lives the rest of his life
confused with apparently no knowledge of
previous events
so once he nuts he's delirious
once he nuts he literally loses his mind
literally i was going to say that's
that's not even posting that clarity
that's
the opposite of post not clarity he's
not clear on anything it's not dementia
post not dementia that's what that is
pnd party next door place not dementia
that's what he's got bro oh these
octopus
so did they have sex once one time in
their life or do they like
regain some stuff at the end of the day
and if i don't know i don't know i don't
know i don't know
that is wow yeah i don't know
that's blown me away it's crazy isn't it
nah
imagine that as a human being every time
you smash you're just like where am i
to be fair for the first like minute or
two i am like that
i am like that do you know what i mean
do you know them once
do you know the ones where you're trying
your best to be quiet and you thought
you were being quiet
until it all simmers down yeah and then
it's just silence you can hear
everything you can hear the blood flow
in your ears and you hit that light
ringing in there and it's up
and then you can hear someone like
coughing next door and you're like jesus
we weren't quite
we were loud we were not quiet um
yeah i'm dazed and confused after a
wholesome um
a wholesome nut you just lie flat on the
bed flat and just
yeah yeah that's it that's a good one
wash me and kiss what
clean me unless i could sleep oh those
are the best ones yeah man but um yeah
fun that's the fun fact of the day
thank you for that you're welcome gee
i've had that on my phone for weeks
gang just ready gang i liked it i really
liked him ah
yeah mania man um what have you got for
me so
let's go with the fan request to start
today
um let's see what i got
ah okay right this one
i have a dilemma i've been i think this
one's going to get us
angry and i don't know why okay i'm glad
you're reading it not me
right i have a dilemma i've been talking
to this girl for over a year
after being rejected at first then i
finally made it and then i finally made
it out of the friend zone and wiped her
gang oh i've read this oh but yeah
continue
um i've been with her oh we've
okay cool spot rhombus is all good i've
been with her for four months and she
seems to think
we are going to get married but what i
want to do is beat
i've spoken to her about it multiple
times but it just ain't happened
and corona means there's even less
chance of it happening
and there's a chance that i could do it
with someone else what should i do
he's 18 out to live his best life love
the podcast i would appreciate your
advice
right um
that that in itself one isn't a dilemma
that's not a dilemma that's not an issue
that's not something you should be
sending us a message about because one
you said you've been chasing this girl
for a while
and once you've finally gotten with her
you say all you want to do is smash
you've been waiting for four months
you said your wife didn't show your wife
do you like her or not
all you want to do is smash that what
we're living in parallel we're living in
different worlds yeah we're living in a
different way
or misses or is she a beast which one is
exactly why would you waste time
trying to graft to get her secure her
after god knows how long
be with her for four months and then say
all you want to do is smash
confusing that is very confusing the
thing is i read that
i remember reading that and thinking
there's no way i'm putting this on the
podcast
sorry there's no way i'm putting this on
the podcast no don't need to
apologize i completely forgot about it
until obviously just now and i was like
yeah yeah
this is an easy solution here yeah
you're cleaning she's not
respect your girlfriend it's not even
about respecting your girl it's about
being honest being truthful and honest
to yourself you're clearly
not man enough to tell someone or be in
a position to tell a girl or whatever
that oh you're you're just here for fun
yeah i'm just trying to
for fun and you've gone the extreme
route
to wife her um bring her emotions to a
completely different level make her feel
like she's safe and secure etc you've
basically manipulated her
just to not you've manipulated for ages
just to not and now you're saying
what he said you know he wants to [ __ ]
up the things or something oh yeah he
said
i'm 18 i'm trying to live my best are
you trying to live your best life
because that's not how your best life
needs to be lived yeah
yeah yeah yeah so yeah you're you're
young guys you might not be
understanding what we're trying to say
here but at the end of the day yeah is
that
is that like um you don't
make a go your girlfriend just so you
can smash yours basically what was
basically what we're saying in this day
and age it's not the 1940s anymore
so i mean in 2021 if you want to smash a
girl you say it with your chest
and if they're down they're down and if
they're not they're not you go home and
you
you bash and you move on that's it man
you you gotta give me someone else and
then you go with someone else and you
move on to the next one like
if that's what you're looking for you
need to find someone you you're
basically being non-consensual do you
know what i mean you're being mislead
like you said your manipulator
because you think the only way i'm gonna
get this nut is if i wipe this girl off
and then you're frustrated about the
fact that she's getting lost in her like
emotions and stuff like granted i don't
know why she's talking about marriage
it's granted you're right in that one
but still
you you put her in a position where like
you said she feels comfortable she feels
safe she thinks she's got herself a
boyfriend
she hasn't got herself a boyfriend she
literally doesn't have a boyfriend she
doesn't she has a guy who wants to [ __ ]
her who's a
who allows her to call him her boyfriend
as long as he gets to smash that is
manipulation
yeah that's not cool bro unfortunately
you're probably gonna like you're you're
gonna
you're you're gonna be watching the
screen and you're gonna be like oh
um dilemma and you're thinking oh that's
my oh my god it's mine
oh oh [ __ ] oh right that's lagging me
off that's not what i thought that's not
why i thought it was going to go
um yeah man if you want to smash over
things do you think bro break up with
your girlfriend and go smash over things
um it's like sorry to cut you off it's
like what james said um obviously
because you're 18 years old you've
probably not
you've obviously not lived a life where
you can understand circumstances and
understand like
um every action has an equal and obvious
reaction g like
that isn't that's not a cool thing to do
whatsoever
and i feel like obviously because you're
you're still young you're not probably
as mature you probably think this is the
only option you've got to try and smash
a girl
or to try and have sex with someone and
it doesn't so
my question to you is now if you want to
[ __ ] someone else
are you going to do the same thing again
are you going to try and wife her and
like coerce her to be your girl and etc
blah blah take so much time to
make her have feelings for you just so
you can continuously smash
do you have actually yeah a weird one my
brother um i don't yeah i don't really
think you thought this one through
you've not thought it through uh it's
not a dilemma yeah it's not
unfortunately he's not a dynamic
i'm not a dilemma if you're trying to
smash and she's not about it
then you're gonna you just you're not on
the same wavelength are you
and you're clearly not in a safe way
because you don't want a girlfriend you
said you're gonna live your best life
so why did you wife her why'd you chase
her down for a year
that's the thing she rejected you and
you kept going and you finally secured
her
it was a match made in heaven everyone's
guessed
but really you just wanted the naan
ah i don't know what it's like to be 18
boys
it's tough because all you want to do is
not you're horny all the time it's
unavoidable whether male or female like
you you are just
those are the sensations you have at a
teenage age because you just want to
smash
but it's not cool to do that man it's
really not cool um obviously we can say
this with our chest because we're 30
years old do you know what i mean like
it's
we've we've grown out of that phase it's
a completely different mentality
so it's hard for us to say this to an 18
year old because we're not thinking as
an 18 year old we're thinking as
grown ass men yeah it's something you
should definitely take
serious take seriously um heed on
because this is not this is not the way
to
to talk to women yeah that's not how to
operate it's not how to pattern anything
yeah yeah it's not how you operate
this is that's how you break cards and
[ __ ] it is you're going a hundred meters
just to secure ten it doesn't make sense
yeah it doesn't make sense man you
should just be up front
because the more time you're up front
the more honest you are trust me it
benefits
you and you're thinking i've won the
lottery cuz how is this possible you
think how is this possible
literally but you won't get it it
doesn't make sense but yeah when you're
saying to a girl like and you're nervous
and you're like oh basically fair i'm
just looking to smash
and she comes back and she's like gang
let's do that then you're gonna think
you're worse
going on that's not what i've been
taught that's what i've seen that's all
the parents told me
from hollywood they don't tell you the
real truth ah they don't you can
literally just say someone hey i'm
looking for something casual i'm looking
for some fun i'm 18. i'm living my best
life i'm not trying to marry everyone
that i'm trying to smash yeah and then
the girls will come around
some people some of them will be like
nah i'm good thanks but thanks for your
honesty exactly they'll actually
appreciate you honestly
and when they're down they'll remember
you know they'll remember and they'll
come back
because they got this girl now let's say
you eventually break up with their work
she's never gonna forget
what you did to her and she's never
gonna hold you again do you know 100
percent she's gonna think you're a piece
of [ __ ]
i think you appreciate for the rest of
not resting for the rest of her life
because i'm sure she won't care after a
certain amount of time
but like james said the ones you are
honest to will come back to you bro
tenfold not it might not even be them
but your honest honesty is away from
yeah just be a good guy just be a good
guy honest good guy
and it just it's not a quick win being
an honest good guy is not good
it doesn't secure you're not today but
it could cause it
won't secure you a nut today but it
could secure you five next month yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah bro
yeah being an honest stand-up guy comes
through bro he comes through but yeah
being a life
lying deceitful snake gets you pum today
it will but it ruined your life it's not
worth it and it's hard to change once
you've
got into that happening when you get
into that cycle or trust me it's harder
yeah you turn into a little compulsive
liar it's horrible that's that is what
you may become into and it's not um
it's not a good look it's like the flex
dude it's not the flex
i'll ask you a question something it's
not that's your longest language
this way is do you ever feel like or do
you ever think a woman has ever fixed an
orgasm for you
that's so weird because um
me and bella were talking about that
yesterday
yeah when i was cooking dinner or were
we all talking about it i think we were
all talking about it
i can't remember um but she was talking
about this she's fake for loads of dudes
she's told me that before and uh and
then i was thinking
i was because i was about to say i think
the reason i thought about it because i
when she said
it i was ready with myself to be like i
don't think anyone said
is it that sounds stressful for you
yeah i'm sorry doing just the the thing
but um it's a very good question i think
maybe i think there have been times
where um we've
missed the mark okay so i think there's
some times where like
we've been smashing i've i've been
smashing a girl or whatever
and you know when you've been seeing a
girl for a while yeah you guys get in
sync
okay so the nothing at the same time is
just standard yeah yeah of course of
course
there's definitely been times where i've
thought i can't remember specific times
i remember the thought in my head where
i felt like we missed the mark
so that maybe she was five seconds away
from where i was
or yeah five seconds further away than i
was but i thought we were on the same
level
so then i finish and she's very very
close
but she can tell that i just can't go
anymore yeah
so she doesn't want to ruin the whole
thing so she just
pretends that she did when she did it i
think that's happened at least once or
twice to me before okay
because because you know when you when
you've been with someone and you've seen
them not loads of times
you can tell when they're faking it now
of course you know what i mean okay i
get i guess yes
if they've done it like for real yeah
you know when they're not doing it
forever
okay yes i get that yeah um so i think
that's happened to me a couple times
where i think like ah we kind of missed
the mark there
um we'll pick up on the next game but um
yeah i think that's happened but in
terms of just like
i don't think it's ever been a case
touch word
i could be completely wrong i could be
completely wrong
i hate being lied to i hate being
lighter but i could be completely wrong
but as far as i know
yeah i've never been like way off yeah
and it's just like
i don't think yeah i don't think it's
ever been a case of someone's completely
fake fitting
for whatever reason to make me stop or
to i don't think that's happened but
then again
everyone says they do it so maybe maybe
it has happened i don't know that's the
thing i feel like
again i i don't know whether it's
happened to me or not and i'm not
i don't want to be naive to think that
it's probably never happened to me
because again like you said i don't know
and she would never tell me yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean yeah yeah it's
also a case of
um it's it's a weird one to it's weird
one that i said because obviously you
were comparing
when you've when you're seeing someone
for so long you kind of know
what their sync is like and when they
are going to come and if it's free or if
it's not but let's say you've just
let's say you're sporadically just
having sex with like two or three
different people
um or you've had a one night stand for
example yo
yes you're out there for the nothing so
because with a one-night stand
the the sex is different i've never made
a one
maybe once or twice but like general
consensus is that
i just don't make one like i don't think
i've ever made a one-night stand or not
because you're not i don't know if
you're mentally there for that yeah i'm
not here for that i'm not here for a
connection
i'm just here tonight i mean
i know what you mean i'm just here to
get mines i know what you mean it's hard
but
they're also there to to get there to
get theirs and but if they don't then
that's not my fault
it is my fault technically but again
like they don't know me because
a lot of the time for a night especially
for a woman a lot of time from that is
all about like the connection with the
person in this
of course so you don't even know me
yeah so i can't that's that's what i'm
that's my thoughts going in
first of all it's five o'clock in the
morning second of all i've never met you
third of all we're both drunk
sensitivity is low yeah
like i have i owe you nothing so
i'm not out here pulling out my best
moves if i don't think i'm ever going to
see you again yeah i'm not
pulling my best moves to make sure that
you get yours it will be nice
it will make me feel better in the
morning but
because i also know that you you know
nothing about me
i have no idea what you like and don't
like and i don't even have the time or
the patience to find out
true true yes if it's one that's done of
course yeah exactly yeah yeah i'm not
going down you i'm not doing none of
that because
so i'm just gonna go for it and then
yeah if you know then you're not if if
if not then um i i couldn't care less i
don't know you broth that's sticky
ladies please in the comments below
just say yes or no whether you've
actually faked it for a guy or not
or send us a dm and we'll keep up yeah
yeah or put it in the comments and just
be like
oh maybe with like a little um little
eggplant
yes eggplant or no eggplant yeah i might
do a poll on instagram or whatever
because i'm very very intrigued
obviously everything will be anonymous
type it for me please gene sorry
um everything will be anonymous but i'm
just very intrigued to know whether
ladies have fakes or not and ladies have
all of them say they have
and i don't know maybe but i don't know
what the motivation to make it is for
they just want to wrap it up it could
well obviously my assumption is
it could be maybe they want to wrap it
up maybe because we've nutted
and they don't want to make us feel
emasculated so they
nut as well so it's like okay this for
for us
it may seem like this was banging this
one's banging and then we can be like we
could go home with our heads hold high
and granted for the ladies like
that's a you're a trooper you're a
trooper for like boosting up our egos
you're having a bad time and you're
worried about my ego
if if i'm having a [ __ ] time in bed you
will know about it
because i've got no other choice what to
let you know about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's
if i'm not hard then that's it like
you're gonna know i'm not right it's
done
yeah yeah you're gonna be wet regardless
or you're gonna be as wet as you can be
so there's only so much you can get away
with without us
knowing or not knowing whereas if we're
not hard then you know we're not hired
oh yeah dude it's it's hard pun intended
but um i don't know whether well like i
said ladies please
please let us know i might do a poll i'm
just i find it very very interesting
very interesting oh i mean tree do paul
now
um true true true true true i'll write
one now on um
on the trap on instagram but yeah
um yeah man um that's very interesting
right so complete complete tangent yeah
um do you remember the first time
when you realized you're probably gonna
say no because you said to me the other
day you don't remember childhood
memories like that
but the day you realized all an event
where you realized ah i'm genuinely
never gonna be like a professional
athlete
in any chosen sport because when i was a
kid i was certain i was gonna be a
professional athlete
uh 110 certain of it i don't
not necessarily not going to be a
professional athlete but i remember
this is going to sound so cliche because
obviously football i remember the period
of time where
i i was playing football religiously and
then one period of time i just stopped
and i just knew that okay this this is
it for me now and it wasn't like a
cliche i had an injury yeah yeah yeah
well just one of those ones where
i hate the fact that i'm gonna say this
because people in the youtube comment is
going to [ __ ]
dig me out for it but when i was in
nigeria
yeah yeah when i was in audrey i played
football a lot um and
even before that because obviously i
went to not obviously if i went to a
rugby school
in year seven so i played a lot more
sports there and i played football quite
a bit in nigeria
and i to my knowledge i was very good at
it
but when i came back because when i came
back to the uk um
football wasn't my go-to i feel like
everyone in my secondary school
was either on basketball or
i think it was just possible well the
friends i hung around with anyway yeah i
was just on basketball yeah
and that's where i started to play a bit
more and blah blah so it wasn't
a case of me trying to excel in
basketball it was just another
venture for me and i was just doing it
for fun so everything football wise
stopped for me yeah yeah just completely
and it's it was weird because it
i didn't even have the motivation to
continue it apart from basketball all i
was doing was running as well like
sports days i'm like 100 meters dash all
of that thing that was me
i loved doing stuff like that but i
never there was never a point where i
thought
damn i'm never gonna make it because i
don't think that was probably in my
forefront i don't think i was ever
thinking okay i really want to do this i
really want to be a footballer i really
want to be a baller yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i just know the phase in which
when i was playing in sports a lot at
one point
yeah and then there was a point where i
just stopped yeah yeah yeah so that's
that was my one
boy i've had like i think i've had two
major
slaps in the face okay wherever i was
like rah
i'm just not up to i'm never going to
make it oh wow
where there was um one was actually
later in life
but i didn't think i was going to make
it anyway but that was just like a
reminder
that i'm never gonna make it that
strokes hit me with that that's
hilarious a reminder you know
oh that's just basically all right cool
so
i do the first one um which was the
earlier in life yeah
so basically there's been times where i
thought i was going to be professional
athlete in three different areas
one i thought was going to be like track
and field i used to think
i'm used to say to everyone go to the
olympics when i'm older i'll go to the
olympics
go to the olympics and then i always
thought it'd be sprinting and i was good
at sprinting
yeah but then once i started doing like
uh like track and field tournaments and
stuff like that in high school
um i was banging a triple jump
for no good reason i was just sick at
triple jump and i would always win
and i was like cool like this is not
something i've ever thought about but
[ __ ] it whatever so um
triple jump triple jump jump and then
i'm doing sprinting on the side and then
i had uh trials for
i can't remember what it was it was
either like
midlands trials or something like
something
underneath whatever comes underneath
england trials yeah that's what i had in
the level of
in the level of iraq of course that's
what i had okay okay so we went to this
massive stadium
yeah and uh basically what happened was
is
i um i broke my toe
i broke my toe so you know how i am
so when i decide i want to do something
i have to do it yeah yeah so one day i
random when i was a kid i was must have
been about
14 or 15. i think it's about 15. i
decided i want to know how to do
backflips
that would scare me backflips it was a
summer so every day after school i would
go home i would go we had a big back
garden as well i would take
my mattress from my room my mattress and
my duvet from my room
and bring it to the back garden okay and
i'll bring one of the dining room chairs
out into the back garden and i'll stand
on the diamond room
and i'll practice trying to do a
backflip onto the the duvet okay
um and i'll do it up until about half an
hour before my mom got home from work
and i was sprinting out like
i said because my mom should go [ __ ]
nuts that's jokes yeah yeah
oh that's hilarious and then one day
my boys i was i went to school the next
day and my boys were like i for some
reason just came up in a conversation i
was like oh bro i'm trying not to do a
black flip and stuff yeah so they were
like oh 666 like
um let me come run and do it and i was
like yeah cool so a couple of my boys
came over after school
the next day and we had so say this is
like thursday
yeah we had a uh this big athletics
tournament on the saturday mm-hmm
so we're doing these backflips dinner
strap flips and then i do one
and i land say this is my foot i land
on my big toe like that so my big toe is
bent and i put all my weight on it and
land on it broke
broke how old did you say uh 15
oh when i say my toes swelled up
imagine swelled up huge bruised all
at my foot i didn't go doctors i think
the hospital didn't do nothing i know it
was broke and i knew it was definitely
broke even till now because even until
now
if i like put if i if i did like went
for like a long run like my toe would
ache afterwards okay
so it was my big toe on my right foot
[ __ ] and i was thinking [ __ ] we've got
this tournament on a saturday
and at that point this is the biggest
tournament i've ever been to so
saturday comes obviously my toes no
better i get my mum to strap
up as tight as possible wait what did
your mom say when she thought
when you told her you broke it um she
didn't believe that i've broken it
um she didn't believe that i broke it
what did you say to her
as to how you broke it as to how i broke
it um i think i told her i was doing
backflips but i didn't mention the duvet
in another thing i started trying to
learn to do backflips
so um anyway so um
on the saturday saturday comes i get my
mom to bandage it up as tight as i can
um and i was supposed to be doing in
this tournament i supposed to be doing
the 200 meters and the triple jump
so i was like i'm not doing the 200
meters i'm never going to make it
but if i can just take the pain for the
triple jump i can probably get it done
so i knew what my records were okay
and i was like cool so we get there
you're sitting down chilling
and i'm like all right cool this is nice
i think i can do it
i'm getting myself psyched up psyched up
and then they give out all these record
books
okay for what was achieved in that
stadium so this is oh this is
this is like uh the fastest hundred
meters we've ever had in the stadium
okay and this is like the top ten and
stuff like that and just the
the names of the people that have done
it so we're looking through looking
through and i'll get them to triple jump
and i'm like let me see the record so
i'm going through the records
and fam they're all the records
i've beaten before okay and bear in mind
all i know about triple jump is winning
every school event and stuff like i just
went so i'm looking to everyone's
thinking
big man that's easy i've smashed these
before not smash them but i i beat these
yeah and i was thinking
[ __ ] i think i could do this i could go
to this could be my team
i'm going to the olympics big man like
this is normal like and i turned to my
mom and i was like mom
like i beat this all the time if i can
take this toe pain i'm set
yeah like if i just get a good job i'm
gonna break the [ __ ] records like my
name's gonna be in this book yeah and
i'm pointing a point in fam
do you know what she said to me she's
like james this is the girl's records
who had i was reading i was so i guess i
didn't read one name
i just read the distance the girls were
on my level
so when i said i beat the records i was
like two centimeters above
and uh literally i was like turn the
page to the boys ones
like two meters ahead of me three meters
ahead of me and i was like no
no [ __ ] way i was like oh my [ __ ]
god
i'm way off what am i even doing here
and then straight after that it's my
turn to jump
so they're holding me down realized i
hopped out i [ __ ] hobbled down there
i'm gonna bust up foot and i look around
all the donnies that i'm jumping against
are like six
four make sense they're [ __ ] massive
and then i look around i think i didn't
even know that was a help i didn't even
know this was the logistics bruv
and i do my shitty little jump on my
broken toe and i [ __ ]
go home with a sad look at my face and
i'm like wow
i'm never ever making it to the next are
you
crazy i'm never going to make it i got
[ __ ]
that is hilarious when as soon as you
said um
like a track and field kind of thing it
brought me back to sports day in year
10.
um when i was in year 10 i was one of
the fastest people in my year
so i'd always used to either come i'd
always place top three in
any like hundred meters relay or
probably two hundred dollars to relay i
love you i was what um leg were you on
the relay
um in school i would be like
last but uh i think we had this weird
one when we used to go to tournaments
like
we had this weird one where we'd
actually like me and my boy my best
friend was first
okay and i used to go last okay but then
we changed it and he said
you go he wanted to go no no no no no
he wanted us to do third and fourth yeah
and he just
in his head he was a bit like a dreamer
like me in his head
he was like it was a guy that does the
art now my friend john okay okay okay me
and him were the fastest yeah yeah so he
was like
he would like sell it like big man don't
you think it'd be crazy though because
obviously you're supposed to go
faster first and faster to last but if
you go third
if we're doing okay because the other
guys that we have will fast as well if
we're doing okay
then you're going to [ __ ] smash it
then i'm going to smash everyone
and i was like that's sick i mean i get
no reward for it
and you get all the glory yeah but
that's cool yeah um
so yes what we used to do i used to do
third going so um
yeah back in and back in secondary
school i'd always used to
i have a run like you said i used to run
first always just run last i remember
when i did um i don't even know it was
like a trout thing but it was sports day
in school and i
i went last and i won my race in a 100
meter relay
for 100 meter relay four by 100 meter
relay and i went i went on the last leg
um and you know when you win you just
get soul gas you run towards
your people i took my top off i was like
starting
i was like okay bet we've got um we've
got a
like an inter-school sports day kind of
thing off ends in an actual
park thing yeah i was thinking okay i'm
ready for this
i'm absolutely right because in sports
day back in back in those days yeah when
you're competing against other schools
it feels like the champion's league
final bro it literally does it feels
like the champions league final
the nerves but the excitement the
adrenaline when you see other schools
coming in when you see the buses pull up
you're thinking i'm gonna murk you man
humans are gonna match you stay in your
bus
you might have no idea the kind of pace
i'm bringing to this team
i used to think in my head like i'm
gonna scoop all your girls cuz
your girls are coming home with us
they're coming on our bus today
[ __ ] your bus they're coming on our bus
today obviously we would bring the
athletes that are running everything and
they'll be on either another boss or
people will stay on that same bus that
are just coming to support and blah blah
blah and sometimes parents will join as
well
so we had fans
so yeah was we were seeing other races
happen uh people are doing like lung
jump
long jump hundred meters blah blah and
then arena came around i was like okay
boom it's my time to shine
i remember i was in i think i ran third
i think
like i was on the um the third leg of
the four by one hundred
and the donny next to me i will never
forget him i don't know his name but
i'll never forget with like he was one
short brother
with uh braids like uh dre oh i say
braids yeah he had braids on i was
thinking
there's no way this guy's smoking me
there's just no way this guy's smoking
me
i got the button i think we got it
around the same time or literally i
literally maybe got just a little bit
before me
and you know as soon as you get it
you're like i'm gone i'm
gone there's no way you're catching me
[ __ ] this
breath and he was on let's say i was
third he was four so he was on an outer
leg yeah
femme when it starts to straighten up
and redder it wasn't even on the
straight
it was on the ben my just this brother
cleaned me and dipped oh i have never
been so embarrassed
i couldn't believe it certain people are
just born different
different he had pace on him bro i was
thinking
how are you this fast man why are they
feeding him in your school
family because i am fast cause yeah i'm
thinking
there's no way yeah there's no way i'm
losing i was so livid
i was so livid bro yeah those ones is so
i hated those ones certain athletes and
you're just like that doesn't make sense
it doesn't make sense you've just
demoralized me now i don't know
what's the point of me even turning up
next time that was probably the reason
that was probably one of the ones where
i was like [ __ ] i'm probably not i'm
never gonna make it
for this yeah that's that was that was
the
the one that made me realize i wasn't
built for it and the second one that i
had
was me knowing i wasn't built for it
yeah but my ego wouldn't let it and then
someone lit like i said the smack in the
face
yeah so this is like a it's kind of
long-winded but the way it all adds up
was just like
so demoralizing bruv so demoralizing
yeah
so um basically what happens is this
that was athletics and this one was
basketball yeah so when i was younger
younger
i was certain that i was going to play
in the nba fan
certainly nba nba i was going to fly to
america
and i was going to be in the nba i don't
know how i didn't know how it was going
to happen
man said nba not even the bbl [ __ ] the
bbl bruv
i was going to play in the nba
for people that don't know what bbl is
not like the brazilian bunting it's the
british basketball league before people
get confused
yeah i wasn't playing in england cause i
was going to go straight to america i'm
going to play in the nba
it's going to mimi and lebron um
in my head that was 100 that was going
to happen yeah yeah and i would play
basketball i had a basketball in my
garden i would play
literally fam snow rain anything i was
posting shots yeah
everything's sleepy whatever yeah and
then um
when we used to stay with my dad over
the summer yeah he lived in this village
and there was no black people whatsoever
and in the middle of nowhere
in this middle of field there was like
this pristine basketball court that no
one ever touched that they clearly just
built for the sake of it and no one ever
touched it
so i would play there [ __ ] all day
every day for the summer just practicing
drills practicing my shots
by myself no one ever to play with all
day every day and i'm thinking this is
the graft
no one's willing to do this did you know
you talked to yourself no one was
willing to work like this
i was dripping with sweat fab practicing
my handles everything just driven a
certain but no
no i'm in the world no i'm putting these
work no one's willing to do what i'm
willing to do
i'm gonna make and that's why i'm gonna
succeed that's hilarious fam
so that was that and then i got like
three years like you're 78 you're night
i became the better and better and
better
until like i was like the best in my
school at basketball right
and then it got on i got on and got on
and then um
i would play for the
basically we had a my team had what we
call
a national league and a local league so
basically
my this is my like towns team so this is
like the weekend nothing to do with
school enough to do everything in the
weekends and stuff so
i would train with them but the coach he
liked me but he just didn't break me at
all
okay he didn't rape me at all okay so i
used and i was boys with a lot of i was
bredrins with a lot of the boys that
used to play on the the national team
right okay
national league so that means that
you'll play obviously all over the
country
um so that's like one step under like
bbl okay national league
and then local league you just play like
in your county okay so
he will always say oh you can play the
local league team and i'm like come on
man
stop [ __ ] around yeah i'm with it
like i'm i'm i'm i'm heavy
and i would play ball with my other uh
boys who played on the national team i
played all of them every single day
so this is like this is this is what i
said this is later in life i was like
probably like 17 18 at this point um so
this is
near around about time i met you okay
and i've gone to basketball camp and i
was doing everything else
you went to basketball this summer
before you know there's some before
union basketball
stuff like that right so i was so on
basketball
and then i used to say to him like bro
i'm hot like it it's long like i can do
it
and then he was like nah nah nah nah nah
nah
so there was this one local tournament
one time
where he was the coach was a referee
this was for a different team that i
just offered to play for
so basically a team approached me and
said oh will you play for us and one of
my mates played for them
okay he said oh we need an extra man we
play for us and i was like cool and then
the my coach
who who slagged me off was ref in this
game so i told him
big man you're going to see me [ __ ]
play now
and i'm going to shut your [ __ ] mouth
and he was like shut up cuz
no you're not you're trash
like squaring up but obviously it's all
doing fun but i think i can't wait to
shut your fat little mouth mate
i said to god i swear to god
so i'm psyching myself up just to prove
my coach wrong of course like
[ __ ] this guy yeah like [ __ ] this guy he
thinks i'm trash for no reason
like i'm not trash yeah bro i played out
my
skin this game yeah i dropped at least
25.
i chose at least 25. and the la i got
the buzzer beat and everything it was
classic okay
classic three i felt like steph curry
found pump fake
and then just drain the three and as
it's in the air as it left my finger i
knew it was going in yeah and i looked
at my coach in his [ __ ] face
and cached it and i was like i ran out
to him fam and i was like
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you like everyone was
thinking what the [ __ ] is going on
because no one knows what we're having
all they're saying is me going up to the
rest saying [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ] you
and he's pissing himself laughing and
then
after he's alright man you're right
you're right and i was like [ __ ] you bro
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you bro you might
think i could do it and now i can do it
so anyway this is obviously just like a
random little game it doesn't mean
anything yeah yeah once again i finally
got my coaches respect
yeah that's gang though sometimes go
that way it felt good yeah
then so this weird is what's happening
my stories i get you up here
and i'll tell you my downfall so anyway
about a weekend
later or two later yeah there's a
tournament in england you might have
heard of it you might not it's called
midnight madness yes
you have right yes of course so they do
these little um setups
in different cities around the uk or
they used to and i don't even know if
they still do it
and you can rock up you can either rock
up with a team of five
or a team of four or a team of three or
you can rock two or one
and they if you if you haven't got five
they'll make a five
so um we rocked up i think with a team
of four
and they stuck us with one prayer okay
um coincidentally the one brayer
actually ended up going to our uni okay
so so
they stuck as they were at midnight
madness and the rules are
um you do all your qualifying games
if you win every match your whole team
goes through to the next round
okay and the next round they'll pick
like what they call the all-stars
to take them to the midnight madness
camp okay and you'll stay at the camp
for like
a week or two okay and then after the
camp they'll pick their starting fives
um from each team and then you'll play
in this big uh arena in crystal palace
and it's like a blacktop uh thing and
it's just like sick
so they do all around the country
and then we went to one in nottingham
so we drove up to nottingham me and my
boys there's four of us and then
obviously there's one extra
guy and we're like cool obviously we're
all trying to get through
less uh let's just win every game and
then we're all going through
i was like cool gang fam went there and
then my boys i was playing with they're
big boy ballers okay let's see so the
guys on your team are sick the guys on
my team are sick
okay sick they're obviously better than
me okay but like i
i could like kind of hold my own they're
obviously way better than me yeah
so um anyway so we're doing doing doing
win the first game when the second game
and that's how many games five there's
like five or six games yeah they're only
quick games like okay 10 15 minute games
fam win the first game when the second
game we're in the third game
um and for some strange reason i've got
the most points out of everyone
and i'm thinking brah but it's not
because i'm doing anything like
fancy i'm just doing like just shoot i'm
just shooting i was a shooter i was just
shooting i was just having a good day
you had the space and the time i had the
space had the time and i was just i was
just on form that day yeah good yeah
i'm cash and i'm cashing and then like i
was like cool fam last game i'm thinking
bro let's go fam won the last game
i'm thinking fellas we're through to the
next round
like everybody's giving me tap on the
shoulder like jason are you playing all
[Laughter]
images again i'm thinking i'm good maybe
i will go to the nba
the little boy ten-year-old james
sweating his tits off he's gassed yeah
he's been kidding the holdback actually
might have paid off
i know i'm already 18 and it's a bit
late but you never know
um i might get scouted in this whole
this whole transition yeah
and the one thing about this one that
made me so motivated to do well
in this midnight manners was that when
you went to the training camp
lebron james came lebron james flew over
to go to the training camp for the day
and just have like a day with the team
and stuff like that i was [ __ ]
stoked brav oh wow and not in a million
years i think i've had a chance of
making it because this is the best
players in the country yeah yeah but i
thought
after that that that last game and
that's been good [ __ ] hell brother
yeah
let's go yeah i've got the source fam
they called out all the names that would
go into the that'd go into the thing
yeah
they called out my three boys
and was supposed to get an automatic
through because you won all five because
we went off
fightings they called out my three boys
yeah
you man are going through everyone yeah
i went for my name
and donnie who was on our team i was
thinking you're not even part of us so
you can do whatever you can fam
i go to stand up when i'm about to call
my name they did not call my name
they just moved on to some next thing
and i was like
[ __ ] there must be a clerical error
i went up to the ref who was running
outside who tallies up all the scores
and i was like my baby man
i'm really sorry they're just doing
their presentations and stuff like that
like they didn't call my name
and he was like yeah you didn't get
through and i was like
yeah we did we went on all our games and
he was like yeah no i know that's the
rule but like
come on bruv and i was like what i said
big man
i had the most points he was like yeah
no but
bro no offense but like come on
you're not like you're not gonna make it
through and i was like
i've never felt so crushed crushed what
and i was like
what are you saying what's you saying
these men are just making up rules for
you guys to just play good
just for entertainment making up rules
in their head
they're like if a team can win every
game
they're probably all good enough to go
through it but man singled me out
and was like we're not letting my man
through they literally thought i was so
trashed not so trash
but just was not up to par to be meeting
lebron james
just not up to party being lbj king
james
fam crushed
crushed did everybody get through nah
okay i was gonna say it was me and him
and he went through i knew he knocked
him out as well
because i felt so deflated so deflated
yeah to only turn to him and he he's
like giving me a tap on the back like
bro next time in it we'll get him next
time i want to be like get your [ __ ]
hands off me bro
i swear to god i'm not the one
i'm not the one not today [ __ ]
bro i'm really living the pain the way
he said it the way he looked down was
like
come on is he literally saying that come
on come on bro like you didn't seriously
think you were gonna make it through nah
you can't say that to anyone
after putting out the performance you
gave i was sweating i've been there for
hours i was starving
i balled for hours and i was like
that ride home i was the driver as well
of course i was every man just lied
i'm just hitch up in the front where
they're kicking my seat like
you look at that annoying baby
i'm just saying that [ __ ]
yeah bro that was when i was just like
i'm not
cut out for this athlete life i'm just
not
cut out there's mediocre guys and i'm
just in there
as far as sports are concerned i'm just
in there and the only sport i wasn't
like that
was boxing yeah but i just wasn't
willing to do it for them
when these men and you were telling me
to wake up at five
as soon as they said wake up at five to
train no i'm just doing this not for me
i don't care
i don't care i'm not doing it i'm never
going to do it
so i can get punched in the face no
sleep and i'm getting whacked up no i'm
not doing i don't care where this can
take me
oh sorry bro fam tragic oh
tragic tragic that would hurt me it did
hurt me g but uh
we move we move move the biggest podcast
in the world nice i don't know
what yeah exactly now i'm running the
second biggest pokemon as well so
uh who's got the last laugh yeah yeah
yeah you're a referee
you little [ __ ] referee he's laughing
now but yeah man that's hilarious it was
tough times but uh
let's do it by the [ __ ] gene let's um
let me grab one
um
oh my god all right this is quick and
easy
this is this is a quick one but it's
like wow okay
i'm 15 and one of my boys started making
one of my boys started making moves on
my girl
she told me straight away so i told him
to stop pursuing
no so i told him to stop but he kept
pursuing
we later went to a party at his and and
i had a three-way with my girl
and his older sister am i the [ __ ]
hang on wait i'mma say it again i'm just
going
i'm 15 and one of my boys started making
moves on my girl
so she told me straight away and i told
him but he kept pursuing
we later went to a party at his and i
had a three-way with my girl
and his older sister that's a lie
i'm not doing this anymore
that is a lie
bro we're living in a different era now
it's a lie
i'm not you can't believe it he's a liar
he's actually a liar
okay let's let's assume this has
happened
yeah i know i it's obviously probably
happening because he's sending some i
don't know
yeah yeah yeah but this was obviously
never happening to us 15 years ago so
that's what happened to me now yes
that's never going to happen
what the [ __ ] man said he's a liar
oh but yeah obviously you're
the [ __ ] you [ __ ] your boy's sister
your boy was well
but we don't do revenge [ __ ] out here
we don't we don't
we really don't but the older sister as
well she's like you're [ __ ] a 15 year
old boy
in a threesome what's going on where do
you live
run me your location because i don't
understand what's happening these man
live in mordor
what's going on i don't know man i don't
know sodom and gomorrah that's where
these men live
what the [ __ ] i just don't understand
how that
how that is a feasible thing to come
about like
you're 15 years old you've got a girl
right how at 15 years old
my i'm assuming your girl is around your
age as well
so how will you convince your girl of
around 15 years old
to have a threesome a threesome
with your boy's older sister
how are you patting in this conversation
god knows how are you patting in this
conversation god knows
and how are you convincing the oldest
sister of your boy
to [ __ ] me how james is right you're a
liar
you're a liar this never happened it
couldn't have happened because there's
too many holes in this [ __ ] story
brother it didn't happen you're a liar
it didn't rely on an achievement that's
what you are
it doesn't make sense that doesn't make
any sense what why are all these mans
just stumbling into threesomes i'm just
deep in it now you're a liar
you're an absolute liar ah that's
annoying
so what the hell and um i did do a poll
during this episode and asked um
i did it on instagram and i did it on
twitter i asked if um ladies have you
faked an orgasm before
um 84 said of course they have
84 of women said of course they have and
quite a few hundred people have read it
or
clicked it rather jesus 84 let me see
the one on twitter
i put one on twitter as well see what
the [ __ ] what it's saying on there
everyone is just faking it
that's a lot you know on twitter 55
said they have oh that's all right but
it's still more than
clearly women are just out here just
uh-huh for no reason don't do that
you don't owe us anything you don't you
honestly don't know us a thing you don't
owe us a thing
but like when i'm in the stitch and i
haven't made you not like i'm just
like we win something we lose a minute
that you're true
we win some and we lose some i'm just
looking at some of the names because i
know
some of them and i'm like oh ross
swears on that's not personally like
know them personally but i know them
through my instagrams you know i mean
yeah
the thing is as well some mandem are
answering i'm like why would you why
would you mess up the whole poll
i clearly put ladies and it's clearly
not for you maybe they identify in it
maybe maybe maybe maybe
yeah but anyway thank you guys thank you
guys that was a funny episode and we
will um
catch you on the next one yeah man peace